what you will not hear me do is say
anything
negative about the incumbent because i
respect her
she has a legacy that she's you know
drawn up in the city and so
i'm going to tell you what i'm for i'm
going to contrast myself
because it's not necessary to tear
somebody down
in order to lift yourself up you know
all three of us
are very intentional about just focusing
on good ideas and i think if you have
good ideas and solutions you don't need
to talk about
anyone else you don't need to put anyone
else down and i think i try very hard
not to talk about anyone else
but it's important because andrew it's i
i just want to sit in this for a moment
because it's important because
young kids are watching young kids are
watching
they are aware of the political climate
and so it's our responsibility as the
adults to act like i like act like
adults
i think just being about solutions and
policy
is where we need to move in in politics
and not like attack ads and putting
people down
because it does nothing well erica sound
like a true teacher
look at that you're like kids are
watching be good
they can see what you're doing
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks boy do
we have a treat for you
two amazing amazing congressional
candidates
rev wendy joins reverend wendy hamilton
who's running for congress
in washington dc and erica rhodes who we
got to know well
on the trail from the early days when we
were running for president
she is running for congress in
california district 30.
it's amazing conversation with two
wonderful women
and really a good talk on how politics
works at a local level and how you can
inspire and create
change and impact right in your own
backyard it's pretty powerful
exciting these two women i look up to a
lot so
you guys are gonna enjoy it rev wendy
and erica rhodes on yank speaks
i have been looking forward to this for
quite some time it is my pleasure to
welcome to yang speaks the yang gang's
own
erica rhodes and reverend wendy hamilton
welcome erica
and wendy thank you for having us andrew
excited to be here why erica and wendy
specifically because they are both
running for u.s congress in california
and washington dc respectively
uh so i i can't wait to catch up with
both of you but certainly a lot of
people are going to be meeting you for
the first time so would love for folks
to hear your stories
on erica you and i met when you were
volunteering for the campaign you're a
school teacher
you were such an aces uh powerhouse
during the campaign
where everyone on my team was like oh
who's this person it's like a house of
fire
in california and then you
decided to take it to the next level
which is to run for congress
uh anyone who's looking for someone
doing it the right way
uh erica is certainly an example of that
where it's super grassroots like just a
lot of
a lot of popular energy so erica let's
hear from you first how has this been
this last number of months
and how did you end up at this decision
because running for congress is a very
very big decision
it is a very big decision and thanks
again for having me
and thanks again for just being an
inspiration to me
and i loved i loved campaigning for you
it's definitely one of the highlights of
my life
um so we announced literally after
george floyd and the campaign
has blown up it has really really taken
off
and i'd have to say shout out to the
yangay because they helped give our seed
money and allow us to expand
um into our community and it is a big
decision but i don't regret the decision
because we obviously need real change
and the policies in which we are running
for and the ones that you are advocating
for that are
most of them are on my platform are
urgent and
for me i'm happy to be passing like i
feel like you passed the baton to me and
i'm taking it
but i think as a teacher and seeing the
disparities in education
and seeing all the social you know
unjustice and
the civic unrest and just wanting to
pull people out of poverty
is why i feel like i'm called to do this
i really feel
like i was meant to do this at this time
and so it is an honor and privilege to
run and i look at it as not even being
a representative like i'm excited to be
a public servant
and actually serve my community and
serve our country
and you know really just change what
politics
should be like can be and what it can be
a model of what it should be through my
district
and wendy you and i connected very early
on in my campaign
where rev wendy just shows up to an
event in dc
uh and this was 2018. this was before
the
the yang gang had really even truly
formed
so imagine imagine our delight when
this this incredible leader shows up to
our dc event says what like heard you
and you were like yup you're right like
let's abolish poverty like that you know
like i and
and so you were one of the pioneers for
the campaign
that was early on and uh you were there
with us the entire way you watched the
entire wave build
you were on the bus with me and evelyn
and the family in iowa making the case
uh so you went through the entire
journey and then you decided to run for
congress
in washington dc which frankly i think
it's going to be news to some people
that dc has
has members of congress so if you could
talk a little bit a bit about your
journey too in terms of
deciding to run well you're absolutely
right i did
meet you back in 2018. a lot of folks
like to call me
ogyg like you are og
both of you are ogyg it's true right
exactly
and you know honestly andrew it was
based on an article
that i saw in new york times where i
read about you you were introducing your
campaign it was called the robots are
coming it was in new york times
back in february of 2018 and what you
wrote in there inspired me when you were
talking about automation
and everything that had really uh caused
donald trump to be elected
other than the things that were being
focused on at the time and you you
introduced the idea of universal basic
income which
of course is not a new idea but for me
it was the first time i had actually
heard of the concept and so i'm reading
it
and you're talking about automation and
how jobs are going to go away and i'm
looking at this and thinking about
having come up in the midwest although
i'm all dc right now
when i saw that i was thinking about my
grandmother and my grandfather who
worked in the factories
in my small town in ohio and how they
had nothing to turn to
when they when those jobs got shipped
overseas
and how a universal basic income and the
idea of that would have been such a help
at that time and you were talking about
humanity first and talking about
uh caring for each other and how we had
lost a sense of that so
that resonated with me as a minister so
i read that article i'm like
who's this dude because you know he's
preaching what i preach on sundays
without a pulpit so i need to um
uh you know about taking care of the
least of these looking out for the
oppressed and the poor and the widow so
it all just kind of merged for me
and for me much like what erica said
public service is ministry
right so it made sense to come alongside
your campaign i just
literally sent you all an email and said
i love what you're saying what you're
doing i believe in it
i see it and i want to help if you come
to dc
you came a few months later and and the
rest was history uh
after that we met we connected and i
just felt
the same connection the same call that
erica is referring to
to help spread that message because the
sense i got from you andrew was just
that that
this was bigger than you your campaign
was so much bigger
than you but there was a message and a
vision that you had and i felt connected
and called to be a part of that
so i i joined you on the campaign you're
right we were on the bus
to iowa i've been on more planes and i
think i slept in a couple of airports
because of the snow i'm sorry i'm sorry
about that i've been there that those
iowa flights were a little bit
unreliable like every once in a while
you were like you were like what the one
flight got cancelled
interesting let's see so how do i
connect i'm in the middle of where
yeah so and i like the snow because i
there was a time where i was i went like
12 hours for you and i was like
canvassing in the snow and i was like
everyone's home right now
and i was able to get up like a lot of
yard signs but one thing i do want to
plug about you andrew that i love
like more than anything is that you
don't need to put other people down
to elevate your ideas and i love that
you were like you're
truly a role model like you have real
integrity character
and that was like honestly one of my
favorite things and
you resonated to people from all walks
of life it wasn't like this
oh you have to be a certain way to get
behind this campaign it was just like
i'm here for everyone and this is a
campaign for any and everyone i went to
uh like my first rally and i left with
friends
right because it was just like this
unifying thing and then reverend wendy
and i have become
really good friends and so i really
appreciate your
that you ran for president and i hope
you do it again one day
oh erica that's so kind um so eric i'd
love to talk
about uh how like where you
uh came from how you grew up uh for both
you and rev wendy because i think it's
really important for people to get a
sense of who you are
i do think that ends up shaping why you
would decide to do something frankly
as uh uncommon as run for congress it's
not a normal thing to do
you know i mean like so in your case you
were born in las vegas your father was a
professional fighter i want to say
is that right yeah my dad was a former
ufc fighter
and my mom she when she retired she
became an entrepreneur she like
kind of um does like trade shows and
like events and um and she like
organizes
those and it's specifically to moms and
babies
um but i grew up in las vegas i'm
biracial my dad is african
american my mom is chinese and german my
mom speaks german fluently
and um i had you know these
working class family and um i
obviously had to um unfortunately had to
endure racism at times but i think that
my parents
being that they're biracial always said
you do you know you always treat people
with
kindness and respect judge people based
on your experience with them
and you know taught me that there's a
pretty good rules to live by
it is yeah my dad's really wise but
you know to work hard and just be a
decent person
and just you know don't be afraid to
take on you know hard things
and i have to say with my parents in
particular
i have brought some dreams to them but
they have never told me that i can't do
something they're always
behind any idea dream or aspiration that
i've ever have
i've ever had and including this one and
my dad actually is the one that gave the
final nut he's like you really loved
andrew yang you really love these
policies
you're frustrated well instead of
complaining run
run this is your time go run and so that
kind of helped ignite it
after george floyd and then um i would
say
what's unique about my childhood was
my parents were very present in my life
but i think
if they had a universal basic income my
mom could have been
more present because my mom worked two
and three jobs at some time
at times and so she couldn't make it to
everything and so i just think about the
the freedom in which one can have to be
present in their child's life
um really knits why this is such an
important policy that reverend wendy and
i are both advocating
for and that you obviously championed
[Music]
when it comes to paying off debt it can
often feel like an uphill battle you got
high interest rates you're resulting in
minimum monthly
payments they just keep this vicious
cycle going
of debt and upstart is here to help you
get ahead
upstart is a fast and easy way to pay
off your debt with a personal loan
all online so whether it's paying credit
cards consolidated high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
a simple fixed monthly payment and
unlike other lenders they don't just use
your credit score which is why we like
them they
use your income level your employment
history they look at all these different
data points in ai to give you a smarter
rate with trusted partners that fits
your world and debt level and you can
receive the funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
with like this five minute online rate
check so here's the deal find out how
upstart.com can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
yang that's upstart.com don't forget to
use our url
and tell them we sent you loan amounts
to be determined based on your credit
income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
[Applause]
so rev wendy you grew up in a in ohio
um and and then you you
did a number of things in a number of
different places uh before
winding up in dc though now you're very
very dc you've been there forever
extremely dc for quite some time
um right can you talk about your
uh growing up in ohio like i was saying
earlier about the story with my
grandparents and how that really
resonated with me in terms of thinking
about the struggle that they went
through
and so from that point on my life really
became about public service about
working in non-profit agencies and
social justice agencies
that were you know able to help people
who were struggling to get by so
growing up in ohio it was a nice
experience small town
actually in appalachia on the river a
small town called portsmouth
and if you crossed one bridge you were
in kentucky if you crossed the other
bridge you were in west virginia i had a
lot of life experiences
that led me to come to howard university
in washington dc that's what got me here
when i was 17 years old
that's what introduced me to dc and boy
was it a culture shock for me
when i got to washington dc i hadn't
seen this many people
particularly this many people of color
in professional positions and so
it was an eye-opener but it has shaped
the woman that i have become i've been
here ever since i like to say
dc is my adult home because this is the
place that raised me
this is the place where i've grown up
this is the place where
i became an adult and so my journey to
actually deciding to run for congress is
sort of rooted
in that experience you you mentioned at
the top of the uh
interview that some people may not even
know that there are congressional seats
to be run for in dc
right and of course uh those who do
understand that's why we're fighting for
dc
statehood we're fighting for that
representation so
we do have a non-voting delegate
position which is what i'm running for
in this moment in 2022
dc's non-voting delegate we also have
shadow senators and representative
positions until we are granted statehood
which we're very close to achieving
but i think for me the thing that drove
me the most of sort
of course being inspired by your run and
and working
on your campaign so closely but i was
getting frustrated
and still do about people who talk about
dc
and sort of lump all of dc in with
what's happening on washing on
pennsylvania avenue what's happening in
washington
as if there aren't eight wards of
culturally diverse
rich human beings uh americans who are
going to work
you know trying to do what we need to do
to to make our lives better as well
and yet we sort of get categorized as
well they're corrupt so when people say
washington is corrupt i'm like well dc's
not
that makes a lot of sense it's true
because you you have you know you have
the national government you're the
capital you have a set of legislators
you have people
but then you have how many people live
in d.c 712
000. yeah that's what i'm talking about
you probably have like like an
additional
uh six to seven hundred thousand people
who are just there living their lives
like doing their thing
um and right now when most people know
is that
it's you know it's a district um
and there's a massive movement for it to
become a state
which is this close to happening and i
remember i think all of us remember when
we were growing up the entire no
taxation without representation
uh you know like like battle cry from um
from our founding last i checked people
in dc pay taxes
hello and pay pay more tax in taxes than
23 other states and you talked about
that population
we also have more residents in the
district
than wyoming and vermont and so you know
we have
this larger population but yet no
representation and we're paying these
higher taxes
so it's absolutely time for us to to get
that representation that we
so richly deserve and we're fighting for
it you said it we're very close to it
there's actually going to be a vote in
the house of representatives the week of
april 19th
and we expect that fully to pass and
then all eyes turn to the senate of
course
which is a whole other conversation but
at least
we're moving the ball forward there's
some momentum for us
the people are involved the residents
are getting excited about it and so we
are hopeful
that dc will be given a voice and that's
why i'm running because i want to be
that particular voice for the residents
and the people in this city
to let them know that we have a separate
identity and we need to be recognized
and not disenfranchised geez wendy you
seems like you might be the right person
at the right time
you know really like in the right place
because it seems like something historic
is about to happen um in
in dc so erica your race
is the congressional the 30th district
of california
um which is western los angeles i
believe
yes like the west valley the west san
fernando valley and you
did something i think everyone can
understand immediately that everyone
kind of aspires to in their lives but
very few people do you won
teacher of the year
my first year of teaching which is
incredible
for developing a science curriculum for
kids that that
helped them learn in new ways uh can you
talk about
how you decided to be an educator and
what your initial experiences were
because a lot of people
i'll just speak for myself but i think
this is pretty universal uh you know
wendy you can
like agree with this probably it's like
we all grew up with teachers
because we're around teachers and so a
lot of us at one point thought to
ourselves
maybe i want to be a teacher
[Laughter]
you know i think that was a very natural
thought for a lot of kids
uh and so did you always know that you
wanted to be a teacher and then what was
your experience
like actually getting trained as an
educator and then showing up
in the public schools so no
i never wanted to be a teacher but um
but what ended up happening was um i
came across this woman
who was like an onset tutor and while i
was in college i was like oh that seems
like a really cool gig to have
you know while i'm in college and then i
just ended up going through the
credential process and i had to do
observation hours
and in the classroom that i was assigned
to we had fifth graders
that could not even read andrew and it
literally broke my heart because i was
in the third grade
and i still i was not fully literate and
so it took
that teacher i still remember her my
parents getting me everything that i
needed to make sure that i can
read and so it was like this instant
connection and then
it was in that moment where i decided to
devote my life to education
fast forward i got my credential
i got my first job and um
i was hired as a science teacher because
my master's degree is in curriculum and
instruction with an emphasis in science
and my principal at the time she was
like gave me
creative freedom she's like dream it up
and for
a first year teacher that can be like
kind of daunting like this crazy
task but i was like you know what how do
i learn
what have i learned through the whole
credential process and i
went to my mentor professor baca who's
no longer with us but she
is my mentor she's shaped how i teach
and i dreamed up something that was
hands-on field trip based
kid-led the constructive constructive
approach to learning
and it ended up getting the kids hyped
about science like
every lesson ever it is a dream
and every lesson every time we were
doing hands-on
experiments and it was so fun and then i
was nominated
to be teacher of the year my very first
year by the los angeles clippers
and then that just kind of catapulted my
career in education
and at the school that i'm at now is
really the model
in which i think education should go
where it's field trip
teachers are paid and compensated well
kids are at the
the priority because i think that's what
education should be
where the kids are where we start with
and super attendance are kind of last
and and i think it's part of reason why
i
want to be it is reason why i want to be
on the education committee in congress
that's like my end goal
that would be so wonderful that's what
i'm working towards and
can i just plug that what's my signature
policy that i'm very proud of
is my kids have a voice to program and
so a
section of my campaign is literally
operated by young people
so they came they come up with events
they write policies they dream up things
and they
run a whole section of our campaign and
so basically my goal
is to cultivate the next generation of
leaders and i have to give
reverend wendy a real thank you because
not only has she helped
give advice to this program but she has
also participated
in different events that my my kids in
my district
have done and i think that's why i want
to speak with her
because right like wendy like will work
with anyone that
has the best interest of young people
and so i just want to just let everyone
know
like she's for real about young people
too and i think that's what we're
missing in education
is letting kids feel empowered and
having a voice
in the process especially when they
don't get to vote
these policies affect them but they
don't get to vote on them so it's our
responsibility
to make sure that they have a space and
room at the table
and so that's what i'm excited about so
i take it you were for my
proposal to lower the voting age to 16.
i put it on my platform
nice i have it on my platform it's the
same thing you can pay taxes might as
well
know where it goes right and one of my
girls on my campaign
she wrote a whole presentation for me on
why it should be
16 and not 15. so kids really care about
this
so thank you for running on that
[Music]
all right i want to talk to you all
about better help i am a satisfied
customer of better help i talk to my
better help rep my therapist and we
talked about a whole bunch of things
mainly i'm just talking about the things
i don't talk about during the week which
is why i like it just an
opportunity to like let off a little
steam
in a healthy way where you're actually
diving into
the things that are going on in that
brain and you can use better health to
talk to licensed professional counselors
that are specialized in depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
anger family conflicts you name it you
don't have to sit in the waiting room
it's secure it's online you can message
i can message sarah at any time it's
pretty cool and then we do
quick video calls it's amazing it's
convenient professional affordable
you're gonna wanna check this out
betterhelp is awesome so i want you to
start living a happier life today do
what i just did and as a listener
you'll get 10 off your first month by
visiting our sponsor
betterhelp.com so check out
what over 1 million people have done
and take in charge of their mental
health by using better health that's
betterhelp
help.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so you've worked in both public and
private schools and this is such like uh
uh you know uh central issue for so many
communities like do you have any
thoughts
on uh what you've seen in different
environments
and what we can do to frankly teach our
kids uh
better yeah there is a difference
and i think what it is is with i think
it really comes down to accessibility
and resources
you know so at you know when you work in
a private school
you tend to have more resources to do
the hands-on
um to have creative freedom to go on
field trips
um because it's you're not working
through a system
um public schools have different
challenges and benefits
right but i would say when i worked at a
public school
the kids were just absolutely astounded
they were just amazing like they
they wanted that they wanted to um
have these same experiences and i think
for me what i had to do
was find ways to fund them and i think
that's that's what i want to fix like i
want to make sure teachers are paid more
and that we are making sure that
teachers have resources
because when teachers have resources we
know that they can flourish
like teachers should never have to pay
for a lesson like i keep like when i was
of course
like all of us are thinking to ourselves
teachers have to pay for lessons
it's wild it's absolutely wild and
you know i can't even begin to tell you
how much i invested in my own classroom
i'm happy to do
it but i mean a teacher so that's not
cool
yeah we shouldn't and so i really think
that we need to reprioritize funding
and make sure teachers are compensated
well and that teachers get stipends so
something that i'm proposing
is that teachers at the beginning of the
year get a thousand dollar stipend
so they can invest in their classroom
and tailor their curriculum to
the resources in which they need to to
innovate and create
and have those hands-on opportunities
and then i think it should be sustained
throughout the school year and obviously
there's some public a lot of public
um policy so i'm
saying that even if i'm in washington
i'm willing to work with our local
officials to make that stuff possible
that's a tremendous idea and one of the
things that i'm hearing
in your proposals which i agree with is
that we should be investing
resources as close to the kids as
possible
and and what's closer than the teacher
you know there's a lot of money getting
spent on stuff that is not
in that classroom
and paying teachers more to me
is one of the first moves you make uh
where and if
you look at the numbers uh we're
actually spending a good deal in the
united states to
uh educate our kids it's just not not
enough it's going to the teacher and the
fact that teachers have to do what
you've done
which is spend their own money that they
don't really have a lot of
excess in to buy materials or lessons
for their kids
it's just wrong so uh like i i couldn't
agree with you more
so wendy on your side you you've done a
lot of things as i
uh said before you who've worked in
communications in capitol hill you've
been a communications professor
you worked with someone who's like a
major major forces
ben jealous who's the ceo of the naacp
who i i know you know like i'm friendly
with ben i like i don't know him well
we have a lot of people in common um and
you've been engaged
in uh criminal justice reform
uh in environmental issues
um and during that time you've also
obviously
become a reverend and been ministering
to people's spiritual lives
i think we've recently seen a greater
intersection between
faith and public service and maybe i'm
just thinking of it because of reverend
warnock's victory in atlanta which i'm
sure
both of you are super pumped about the
same way
yes this is a city
that is ripe for someone who
is looking to come and be involved in a
culturally diverse active engaging
group of citizens who really care about
their future
you mentioned ben ben jealous was the
youngest
president in the history of the naacp
back in 2008
when i came on alongside ben who's a
dear friend now who's actually
now the president and ceo of people for
the american way
which is a non-profit here in dc so
working with ben and even working at the
headquarters in the naacp was an
eye-opening experience
i was with ben during the time that
trayvon martin
was killed uh there was a big death
penalty case with troy davis for those
who might remember troy davis who was on
death row
um and a lot of advocacy work that went
into
attempting to save his life and so
as you mentioned i was in this sort of
social justice service people
uh space that give gave me
such a sense of wanting to do more and
and help because there's such a need
and it can almost feel overwhelming at
times you you think you're you know
you're putting out one fire here and
then
something raises up over there and so
having been sort of a person of faith
but not necessarily in ministry
i finally decided to explore that and
actually
when i was working on the hill you
mentioned that i did work on the hill
for a season in a
as a communications capacity they had a
bible study there
that was led by the current senate
chaplain
uh barry black admiral barry black he's
the
chaplain of the senate he's the first
african-american to become the chaplain
of the senate
wonderful guy turned out to be a mentor
of mine actually wrote my recommendation
letter to go to seminary at howard
university
so howard for me uh transformed my life
both as an undergrad and then going back
on the master's degree level
and i knew from that point on that it
was my
calling to serve and to reconnect and to
inspire
and to motivate people to be what
they've been called to be
and to do what they've been called to do
and so the
any types of activities i've become
involved in i'm
inspired by them i don't do things for
clout or do you know so some people
would say
why congress like you know i you know i
kind of got that question one of the
things we haven't talked about
uh is that similar to erica we're both
running against
incumbents uh 30-year incumbents
and so you might imagine you have two of
us coming along with all of this yang
energy you know
and they're like oh yeah yeah energy i
like the sound of them
you know and they're asking you know
where did they come from and what are
they attempting to do but for me
i believe in i believe in stepping into
roles that you feel connected to
you know i know when you were running
people used to say why'd he start out at
president why didn't he start out you
know at
city council or something like that and
like you
the problems were so big you feel like
you need to be at the top
of the of the heap to make any kind of
indentation
into them and so for me also
understanding my gifts
i am an advocacy person i know how to
to visualize and to speak and to
represent if you need my voice on the
record
about what is right and what is just and
what
needs to be done in this moment for this
particular group of people or even for
this individual group
that's me i'm your person and that's why
i'm running
you will definitely be a voice for the
people and you get the sense and we'll
come back to this monday it's like it
doesn't seem like that people have had a
voice in dc for
quite some time
[Applause]
all right mother's day is around the
corner and i bet if you're listening
this
you haven't gotten a gift yet but don't
worry we're gonna cover your ass
literally because i want to talk about
hello tushy's brand new 3.0 modern bidet
yes we are still doing bidet ads on this
podcast because of there's so
many good reasons to be using a bidet it
cuts down with toilet paper costs
they're easy to install
this new hellotushy 3.0 bidet cleans
itself with the smart spray automatic
self-cleaning nozzle
this thing attaches to your existing
toilet no electricity no tech support
face times
nothing and it cuts your toilet paper
used by eighty percent which can get
expensive
so literally the hello toshi bidet pays
for itself in a few months plus
there's a 60 day risk-free guarantee and
a 12-month
warranty so give the gift of a clean but
go to hellotushy.com
yang to get 10 off plus free shipping
this is a special offer
for our listeners around mother's day at
hellotushy.com
for 10 off hellotushy.com
[Music]
[Applause]
so erica let's talk about your race
you're running against
a democratic incumbent who's been there
a long long time
the dynamics of california are
interesting where i believe there is a
relatively open primary
is that correct or is it a democratic
primary before it reaches that level
it's so it's it's an open primary so
it's
whoever gets the top two most votes and
then they move on to the general
and in the past it's been the incumbent
and a republican but
but not this time that's right not this
time
i look at it like this i'm not running
against an incumbent i'm running for
something
i'm running for our next generation to
end poverty to fix our education system
criminal justice reform and my race is
uniquely
a historic race we've never had a woman
we've never had an african-american
we've never had an asian we haven't
it has never been um it's always been
like the same typical
type of um leader and so i'm running to
make history
and i'm running for change and so what's
unique about
my district is they're salivating for
change they want change and i think
that's why we've had
such an outpour of support like
literally today we were at the park
doing our lending libraries because i
want to create a community of readers
and people all over the park were just
like coming around us like what is this
what are you guys doing this is so great
yes this is what we need and i think
that's what makes me
so um unique and different is that i
have a vision for my community i'm not
there to just sit on a seat just to
just vote for something i want to do
stuff that's not even
like you don't have to worry about
legislating it because there's stuff
that we can do
day to day within our own community that
doesn't even have to be passed
through law right and i think that's how
we have to change the political
landscape like what can we do
while we wait for everyone to rally the
votes like what are things that we can
do
as a community and that is what i love
most about my campaign it's so community
driven
like we passed out hygiene kits we
passed over out
over 250 hygiene kits to those
experiencing homelessness
we've done diaper drives there was like
a food bank line
that was two miles long i could have
drove past that line
no i pull over and i'm going car to
carter car what do you guys need and
these are moms
we're waiting for a diaper yes we're
waiting for diapers for our babies
and so within 72 hours i reach out to
our local leaders
people in the community we raised over a
thousand dollars worth of diapers for
these moms
wow and that and that's not law and so
that's the kind of leader
i am i'm present i know it's happening
i have a i know what everyone cares
about i walk
i have literally talked to over a
hundred small business owners
over a hundred and many have said you're
the first person to even come and ask if
i'm okay
that's not leadership and so the
incumbent is like the least of my
concerns
my community is my priority and i'm just
ready to serve i just like i'm just like
june 7 2022 vote me in let's get this
done and let's get
real change and and that's what i'm
really really excited about my district
is
they want the change they're rallying
behind me and we're gonna get it
wow well eric i've seen you in action uh
no one has anywhere near the energy that
you do
really i think people can sense this i
love the fact that that you declared
early
um and that you're just making the case
to the people and there's a very clear
sense that you have a very long time
incumbent who's
been there for decades uh and then you
have the scrappy energetic
grassroots teacher led campaign that
everyone loves and anyone who
interacts with you would be like wow if
she was my like congresswoman that would
be
dynamite
[Laughter]
and you know i think for me it was like
at first everyone's like you're never
gonna do it you're a long shot it's a
long shot
well it's not a long shot because as a
no-name scrappy teacher
we reach over 80 000 in small dollar
donations i have more small dollar
donations than the incumbent
we have donations from every single
state america samoa puerto rico dc
everywhere and we and we're not a long
shot anymore we're very very viable but
it's going to take everyone to continue
to support and help
get us to the finish line and i think
whatever when he can appreciate was like
was it adam that lifted moses is armed
up and pushed him forward i think
that's the story it's like i just need
the community to keep pushing
me forward because it pushes us forward
i would certainly not bet against
uh you making this happen eric and i've
contributed to your campaign
and i would and and i would i
recommend that everyone who's listening
to this donate to erica's campaign
because wouldn't you love to see someone
like erica in in
congress we've got a bit more than a
year to build up her campaign to the
point where she ends up in the top two
uh and then i think if the people gotta
look at what she's bringing to the table
relative to the incumbent she'd have a
great chance to win she's exactly the
kind of high character or public servant
that people
imagine that they want to have run for
congress and then now that she's
actually doing it
you know getting behind her is uh joy so
i love the fact that you started early
erica and you're just
frankly just going out work uh everyone
else
that's the plan no i can tell i mean
everyone everyone listening to this can
actually
tell and you campaigned for me in iowa
nevada
new hampshire of course in california
i've seen you in action and i would not
bet against you for anything
you would run for anything i wouldn't
bet against it
so so uh rev wendy you have like another
situation where it is like a very very
long term incumbent and
there is a lot of potential there i
think for this office particularly if it
converts frankly to becoming a voting
member which could happen
in a matter of weeks you know if
like if a couple of republican senators
uh you know decide to
to uh make it happen um so if you want
to talk about the dynamics of your race
because i'm sure a lot of people when
you're going around dc
say the same thing i said at the open
which is like we have a member of
congress like what's this like
they probably barely even know that this
person is like out there
well well let me say this they do know
they do know uh
most dc folks are familiar with the
setup and what we have here
the issue becomes are they excited about
what we have here
and i know that you've talked about it
and one of the things that we're looking
at
and certainly can't be a part of your
campaign and not learn how to read data
right
and so we're focusing on the data and
what the data is telling us
is that turnout has gone down over the
course of the time that the incumbent
has been in office because people have
become more and more disillusioned and
disconnected
wait wait wait let's have some fun with
this for a second so the folks in dc
like what can they vote for
it's like because you're saying
turnout's going down like you can kind
of imagine people in dc being like oh
what am i voting for like what like you
know
well you know most of our most of our
voting is driven by local races right
the mayor
the count city council the anc chair and
then of course you can vote for
the the delegate position that i'm
running for we also actually have
shadow senator positions so it's kind of
like if we did have senators you could
vote for them so we do have two shadow
senator positions
and a shadow house of representatives
okay wait wait wait just for fun just
for fun
do these shadows like do these shadow
senators have like a full-time job where
they their job is just to chill out
because that that would be
wild so they have like a symbolic office
they have like relationships that they
can build so they um
are somewhat active but mostly locally
and around statehood issues not
necessarily
on the federal level do they get paid by
the federal government
no okay okay
i'd be like we're doing we're paying
some shadows i don't know that that
would be
not to say i mean it's a trivial amount
of money in the scheme of things but
still i would just would have been a
funny thing yeah no more symbolic than
anything else the incumbent who i'm
running against
is well known here in dc and so yeah i
am going to say and i do say
to people i'm not running against her
i am running for dc like i'm running for
the people i'm running
to be the voice of the citizens i want
them to feel like they have a full
representation i want them to know
that you know when the new jersey
delegation
or the california delegation or the
texas delegation weighs in
the dc delegation is going to weigh in
as well and we're going to weigh in
with what the needs are of the people
and so
yes it is a different kind of a race and
what you will not hear me do
is say anything negative about the
incumbent because
i respect her she has a legacy that
she's you know
drawn up in the city and so i she's my
elder
i i've been raised properly so you won't
hear me campaign negatively
about her at all i'm going to tell you
what i'm for i'm going to contrast
myself
because like erica was saying earlier
it's not necessary to
tear somebody down in order to lift
yourself up and so
that's where we've turned our focus and
that's what i've been doing
and i've been taking my message to the
people andrew because that's what's
going to make the difference
when i'm out there on the street and i'm
talking to dc residents themselves
they are saying to me what is really
happening
over there on the hill that's going to
impact my everyday life
i'm not seeing enough of a difference
that's motivating me enough
to come out and to vote so we have good
high registration across the wards cor
you know people are
they're registered but when it comes
time to turn out
um in 2018 the last midterm not 2020
because you know 2020 was kind of an
alcoholic
yeah sure yeah but if you look back to
the previous midterm and we all know
that
midterm turnouts tend to be a little
lower anyway
um just folks maybe they're burnt out
after the general they forget so
please please come out for the midterm
but uh in the 2018 midterm
out of the 493 000 likely voters here in
the washington dc
area 89 000 participated
in the in the voting a little over 18
like that is to me very low but it also
shows me that there's some opportunity
there to grow those numbers
but i need to first advocate and to talk
to people and find out
why are you not coming out what does not
inspiring you
to come out and want to take charge of
your future in charge of your destiny
and i'm having some wonderful
conversations with our residents because
at the end of the day
they are the ones who are going to
decide who they want to represent them
and so we're very grassroots as well
we're very much
you know raising money across the
country thank god for the yang gang they
have been incredibly supportive
please please support i've only been on
the campaign trail about four months
uh so i i'm still uh you know kind of
coming out of the gate and we're really
moving into that next phase now
that the weather is breaking and people
are more vaccinated so we can get out
there and do a little bit more in person
and some canvassing and things like that
so definitely need the resources
but at the end of the day andrew for me
my race really is going to come down to
the people the residents of dc and if i
can
build a relationship with them and they
can trust me what i want them to know
is they have the power to change their
future
by changing the people that they have
representing them
and i will be a candidate who not only
commits to making that change but allows
myself to be held accountable
by voters if i'm not doing what i said
that i was going to be voted in to do so
they'll see me in the district you know
there's been a history
of folks getting over there on the hill
getting the positions and then not
coming back into the district
they'll they'll see you for sure so
is is it a democratic primary for you
officially too is it also next summer
yes it is same day june 8th june 8th or
7th
2022 big day
[Applause]
you know can i just plug something that
she said that's very important
is the clean campaign you know all three
of us
are very intentional about just focusing
on good ideas and i think if you have
good ideas and solutions you don't need
to talk about anyone else you don't need
to put
anyone else down and i think you try
very hard not to talk about anyone else
but it's important because andrew it's i
i i just want to sit in this for a
moment because it's important because
young kids are watching young kids are
watching
they are aware of the political climate
and so it's our responsibility
as the adults to act like i like act
like adults
i think just being about solutions and
policy
is where we need to move in in politics
and not like attack ads and putting
people down
because it does nothing well erica sound
like a true teacher
look at that you're like kids are
watching be good
they can see what you're doing i can't
speak highly enough about both of you
i've
worked with both of you i'm so proud to
have played any role
at all in the fact that you are taking
on
these races i would love to see you in
congress
so erica if someone wants to help what
can they do
um and how can they they find you
okay this is big because we are
grassroots so if
you are so inspired and want to get
behind this movement which i hope you
are
um you can go to our website a a i saw
my name with 2a so a-a-r-i-k-a
for congress.com and you could donate
what i would really love
is for people to become recurring donors
this is important because it helps
stabilize our campaign so we know how
much money we have coming in every
single month
so if you could be like a five to twenty
five dollar recurring donor please and
thank you
and then also follow um me on social
media on instagram it's erica for
congress two a's
and then on twitter it's a-a-r-i-k-a
rhodes
and that would be a big help and then if
you live
in california's 30th congressional
district show up to events
participate be active because this is a
community event and
a community campaign and so we we need
to show up and show out
in meaningful ways and get involved and
we want
our community to be involved so those
will be like the big ways to
to help and if you're on social media
erica's got this uh
apple icon that's sort of the teacher
you know what i mean how like you bring
the apple to the teacher
yes rev wendy if someone wants to help
you and they're probably a lot of people
who live in dc who are listening to this
how can we help
yes vote for me let me start there
let me start from the end and come back
again vote for me
absolutely you can give to my campaign
we are definitely in need of
of operating funds and and growing our
monies and recurring donors so
revwindyforcongress.com that's
revwindyforcongress.com that's the
website
i'm on twitter at revwind3 we're on
facebook
we're on linkedin we're on tick tock i
mean you name it we're on it and
we most recently announced that we have
the capacity to accept donations
in cryptocurrency wow we're very very
very excited
that's right imagine having a member of
congress who did that
that's like yeah very very much about
forward-thinking policies
cryptocurrency is like an economic
justice tool for me because of the
access and the equity it would provide
and opening up
uh participation in our economy so it
ties into my policies
and that is why we made that um an
option
not just a publicity stunt but i had a
clubhouse conversation with folks
from the community so that they could
help inform me
as a potential member of congress of
what their issues and concerns would be
on a federal level
i did not know that there's actually a
congressional blockchain caucus
as we speak on capitol hill didn't know
that but i'll sure
show up at the meeting if i get there
but yeah those are ways that you can
give to my campaign
and we would really appreciate donations
at this time
we are about to blow up we're we're so
excited especially those in dc
but again at the end of the day even
with all of this
national support that we're receiving if
our folks in our districts don't come
out to vote for us
we're not going to get in right so at
the end of the day it's about our
community it's about taking our messages
about
sharing the word so if there's anybody
on here who knows if you've got
family members in dc or in district 30
in california
call them if you've got colleagues let
them know
spread the word that's how grassroots
campaigns grow
like you said early on in this andrew i
remember when we were throwing stuff in
the back of a van to go up to uh
baltimore for one of your first um
yeah it was quite honest yeah no i
remember of course
there's some brewery in the back you
know that's how everything starts
um but incredible things can result
and you too are both just really
awesome human beings i love you both and
your journey is just beginning
because you know we we have a bit over a
year to make these things happen but
we have to do it right now so that
they're in position to be able to
uh capitalize on on the times to come
thank you so much erica thank you so
much rev wendy
you you you too inspire me and i know
that's true of a lot of other people
who are listening to this and seeing
this right now let's go erica andre
wendy all the way to congress
fantastic yes thank you both so much
thank you so much andrew and i just want
to also say one last thing
you didn't have to do this you didn't
have to make your national platform
available for two women of color
who were running for office and yet you
did and i know that that speaks to who
you are
as a person and we will always stand up
and defend
represent and let people know who you
are at your core because you are a good
man
and you're a wonderful human being and i
am so grateful
that god brought all of our past to
cross you seriously i echo those same
sentiments you
like your campaign when i saw you on the
breakfast club it really
it changed my life you know i mean i'm
just grateful to you
and uh i really really want to see you
go all the way so that's what i'm about
[Laughter]
i feel it i feel it
[Music]
you